el presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez ha viajado este jueves por
sorpresa a la capital ucraniana para
reunirse con el mandatario ucraniano
y se trata del Tercer líder de un país
occidental que viaja a quieven pocos
días después de los desplazamientos de
la primera ministra italiana Georgia
meloni y el presidente estadounidense
Joe biden como en anteriores ocasiones
el viaje ha estado precedido por el
anuncio de un nuevo envío de armas en el
caso de España se trata de seis tanques
leopardo que según el Ministerio de
defensa español llegarán a este país en
los próximos meses un mensaje por tanto
de cercanía a pesar de las dificultades
de los países occidentales para
abastecer las necesidades de Ucrania en
el campo de batalla y que se produce un
día antes de este primer aniversario de
guerra en Ucrania hace un año nos
encontrábamos en esta ciudad para contar
esta guerra que se ha revelado
catastrófica para este los países miles
de soldados han perdido la vida más de
siete mil civiles también han fallecido
8 millones de personas han huido de sus
casas y no han vuelto cinco millones son
desplazados internos y la economía de
este país se encuentra completamente
destrozada y tardará muchísimos años en
recuperarse